yeah hello and welcome to this video mr.
God's not oh my god play it's a circuit
and then they come up with c3 okay oh
yeah not that it's a bad line it's just
uh yeah actually wanted to play the
night off all openings and then you get
this um yeah what is the deal here I
think you think you're right that's the
point so what's going on here if I take
a tune this is probably wrong you just
take you the pawn wow that looks okay
right I was thinking night takes could
be critical I know a three and one is ok
but I'm so liking Blackie ever good what
a good coming on d5 yeah check
so good anti a QP position here for
black I mean good and being okay not to
know it's not better for Black Knight to
d2 yeah some night night b3 and playing
Queen a for that that look strange yeah
i think i could play against the poor
Nia mean one principal problem of when
when you play against IQ peers and
sometimes I'm here white can get an
attack on the king and this is miles
away em from happening
and I don't turn it's not so much about
blockading here by the way with night if
I want to play Bishop f6 to get more
attacking power against the deep on 95
no right I don't know yeah I can't wait
for a moment down by g5 is not
threatening here I think
so what to do here Bishop of six I think
this is probably unavoidable anyway so
let's do it the bishop on g7 s is
ideally placed Roxy five i think is not
doing that much before this is a move
that white has to be quite cautious
about what is he doing here I thought he
was playing on the kingside somehow yet
the weekends I think White's position
more than anything no I'm trying to go
to f5 now
I don't know maybe you can take and take
you five two straight down to something
that is worse but not terrible it has to
be a little bit observant in the long
run he will be stuck with the weaknesses
hmm mr. Gardner you have to move some
time I came Queen to be three I can take
a pawn right what is that somehow
poisoned pawn Knight takes Queen them
the Queen would move back and take one
f3 so i think i can take ya every sign
with check so
man that looks nice yeah one issue in
this game was that he never had any sort
of control over d5 and this is really a
paramount in the iqp positions so here
it's a pawn but it's not clear that I am
that I'm winning so where'd you go f6 of
b6 okay so he's not threatening to take
it I need to unpinned oh I wonder rugby
7's good rookie 749 f6 know
now I have 60 I think I'm happy to to
trade clock night if for one is there
anything better here 94 and then Queen
you for something like that looks good
it doesn't have a chick liquid water
please and now i just put it here it
centralized and attacking f2 so here
it's the tactic I don't know yeah I just
go here and night 65 is a good square
and I'm attacking the a pawn so I trade
Queens I should be very ok now ok take F
to enter bishop so take another poem
yeah it should be very likely be a time
when at the end so we're training Queens
here or not probably yes
entirely safe here which is which is
noise okay white for fights on time yeah
the doc you p position is going to be
quite quite promising understand okay I
think this time in orbit should be one
is off I think this idea is sometimes
happening in this line I believe but
this is probably the wrong wrong time to
do it you should take with the night now
which probably gives me problems I
cannot take on a true because of Bishop
b5 I think analysis and have no
development here that is pretty awful
and if I cannot take a two or this was
kind of disastrous oh the opening stage
was pretty awful this may be I don't
know I'm just I was just playing this
without a detailed knowledge but after
this I'm suddenly okay I have this
threat now so why uses this time and
tent here I have a quality safe locate
over t5 getting some pressure against
the porn and blockaded and now we have
to I have to what's the wrong button I
have to coordinate things Oh technically
didn't see this tactic it's a nice one
yeah getting this this Bishop here
that's very nice position am having a
huge pressure on d4 without any problems
yeah i was playing purely strategically
I could have taken again on before okay
but you know maybe after the last couple
of games which were pretty disappointing
I'm I just wanted to play something
yes simple some of the engine wants me
to do this and play come to a 5 this is
the idea it seems so supposedly very
good for black I was snatching this big
center / one cannot be bad yeah I know
if you've tried it things get fairly
easy that because with with queen and
turn with a green on d4 and Adams you
have it's very coordinated position now
the King on g7 can never be checked and
everything else is working together very
very nicely yeah ok guys thanks for
watching